i'd like to uh open the subcommittee
meeting to hb 1644 representative
cal representative
mcgee excuse me i'm opening the meeting
to the subcommittee of 1644
and before we move further uh i'd like
to invite um
representative kelly pitch could you
lead us in the pledge of allegiance
of the please states of america and to
the republic for which it stands one
nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you representative
welcome everybody to the subcommittee
meeting again hb 1644.
uh
before we get into things i just want to
introduce the members of the
subcommittee which is
representative um nick white
representative jeannine notter
representative kelly pitts
representative partial is a member of
subcommittee member who apparently just
walked in
and myself we
these are the voting members of the
subcommittee
excuse me representative mcgee do you
have a question
no no you're certainly welcome to be
here you can take your name plate away
so we don't confuse you with a
subcommittee member but you're welcome
to stay here and we may even ask
questions and people this is
this is
excuse me okay
um let's um
get down to business here um obviously
we're here to discuss
1644.
um
you know there are various options we
can do we get otp at otpa we could
vote for interim study we could vote
ietl it and we could also put an
amendment in all those options
uh are on the table
but i would suggest that
only one or two of them would really be
an option at this time
of a practical nature
representative
do you have a question
uh yeah i've been doing a lot of
research over the weekend
the more i read the more confused i get
including with what we have done
in the past which was deep
we kind of direct
i can't get up there
we kind of um
deregulated the telecommunications
industry and gave up our control of it
and
uh
i wondered
where that this bill fits with state
regulations since
i believe
that we do not have that anymore
well thank you for the question i i
don't believe we have that control over
this as well i was going to get into
that at a slightly uh different time
uh i was going to suggest that maybe we
should have a
short brief um
scientific uh briefing from
representative white on wavelength or
something i i asked you to look into
some
just for the general knowledge of
everybody what are we talking about in
terms of 5g wavelengths and where they
fall into the spectrum
and how they're how they affect your
dawn effect
i wish you would have sent me something
in writing because i completely forgot
um but representative knotter's uh
sheets here are actually pretty good
summary of everything in terms of
frequency what what types of technology
are on what frequency the power levels
things like that
um so if there's any specific questions
we can definitely dive into those if
anyone has anything um
uh representative nader would you like
to talk to your briefing
sure
the technology part of this committee it
doesn't come easy to me so in order for
me to learn i have to write things out
so i started out with this
just so i could have a visual like what
it all means i uh
spent a long time on the phone and
communication with the scientists to
help me to explain everything
and then i took all of that and i
figured out that in our legislative
email account we have
the ability to create a powerpoint which
i've never used before so this this was
my first one so if it's not perfect i
apologize
the title page is 5g
what is it what is it it's an encoding
technology
not a frequency nor the power of the
broadcast the thing being broadcast
isn't the problem
the voice versus data makes no
difference to the risk of the given
signal
if you turn the page
we have 600
megahertz to 900 megahertz
and this is low band
frequency used by all cellular
communications since the 19 early 1970s
that's where the channels 14 through 71
for tv reside
base frequency of all cell phone
companies it goes over mountains and
hills it goes through objects like walls
the old bag cell phones could broadcast
at 5 watts the new hand
held cells at one watt
tv stations broadcast at 50 000 watts so
you're going to get more radiation
driving past the wmur tower
than
holding a cell phone to your head for a
year
therefore more damaging
if you block 5g in this frequency you
block all cell phones in most tv
stations
you turn the page to 1700 megahertz to
2.6 gigahertz this is mid band
in this frequency cell phones broadcast
at .04 watts
towers at no more than 5 watts
wi-fi is 2.4 gigahertz a microwave oven
is 2.4 gigahertz now this has been used
mid-band since 1992 with 2g
it's currently used in cities without
these frequencies cell service doesn't
work in cities low band doesn't have
enough bandwidth megahertz to handle all
the users
it goes through walls and through
buildings but at half to a third as well
as low band
2.4 gigahertz again that's your
microwave oven standing in front of it
defrosting a chicken you're getting more
radiation than weeks of using your cell
phone
using these frequencies for cell service
instead of cable and satellite equals
less radiation received
before the fcc converted it to cell
phone use
2.5 gigahertz used to be used for
satellites 150 000 watts in frequency
17 to 19 1700 to 1900 megahertz was used
by the military and scientists
gps is 2.3 gigahertz
so now we turn the page right 3.2
gigahertz to 3.8 gigahertz this is
microwave it's currently being set up by
verizon and a tnt
this is what interferes with the planes
since sputnik use c-band satellites
broadcasting 150 000 watts to over 500
000 watts by soviets
parts also used by cable and regular
phone companies to broadcast between
distant towers before affordable fiber
cable tv
that was converted to digital in the
1990s
so the six foot
plus dish dishes you know that people
used to have in their front yards
were in this band at a hundred thousand
times higher power than self phone
services the same power as 2.5 gigahertz
and above
the issue for planes is a loom they're
aluminum with miles of thin wire so that
makes the plane a massive antenna plus
interactions between low power so ac at
60 hertz get
gigahertz megahertz sorry in wires and
planes so the human body is not made of
aluminum and we're not an antenna and
our wires our nerves are much better
insulated than plane we do not oscillate
at 60 hertz
it goes through walls poorly it does not
go over hills
it's affected by trees so even the
leaves on the trees will affect it it
works well in cities to add speed speed
but can't stand alone
so now we turn the page and we're at
five gigahertz to seven gigahertz this
is wi-fi we're using it now if you have
wi-fi same power that cell phone company
used for mid bands and microwave it does
not go through walls this is why it
drops going from room to room which
happens to me all the time
wi-fi has dfs sections it requires wi-fi
access point to listen for radar signals
and turn it off and not use those
frequencies if they hear anything why
because ground radar uses these
frequencies for tracking planes it's
getting very dramatic now if you hear
the cell phone over here at 100 000
watts of power
200 000 times more powerful than what
you are exposed to with wi-fi
so now we turn the page and we have 12
to 60 gigahertz
mm wave this is the one people say make
them sick it has a higher frequency
all satellite weather mapping is done in
18 gigahertz
100 to 200 000 watts of power constantly
overhead broadcasting down on us
the space station is 12 gigahertz
broadcasting down on us the military
uses this frequency the frequency is so
high that even glass will weaken the
signal making it all but useless in a
cell phone
used they use this in outdoor stadiums
it does not go through walls so the
walls at your house block it
we turn the page at 78 gigahertz this is
your car's collision avoidance system
emergency braking et cetera
frequency at similar power levels to
cell service but constantly you are
being subjected to it constantly every
time you drive an older vehicle
now we turn the page we have three
thousand gigahertz to seven hundred and
ninety thousand gigahertz visible light
and ultraviolet light
visible light is three thousand
gigahertz to seven thousand six hundred
fifty gigahertz it's 400 to 1000 times
higher frequency than your car let alone
cell service
ultraviolet light is 30
petaherds which i've never heard of
before to 790
terahertz again i've never heard of that
or 790 000 gigahertz this is where
ionizing radiation begins all cell
phones and other broadcasts are
frequencies below visible light vastly
less powerful powerful vastly less
frequency than light from the sun
visible light can't cause dna or other
ionization
no evidence that anything below visible
light can do anything other than warming
the skin so when i hold the cell phone
to my ear it my head gets hot and it
bothers me
low voltage versus high voltage low
voltage electricity is safe to touch so
that's like if you put your tongue on
the nine volt battery whereas high
voltage like grabbing a power line will
kill you
so the next page talks about ionization
process of electromagnetic waves being
so energetic it can actually break off
electrons and atoms
from atoms and cause
charges to accumulate on the particles
that cause them to have energy absorbed
that they wouldn't otherwise and then
split them apart
split apart the molecules that make up
the dna which is protein chains
to induce ionizing radiation you have to
have both high frequency and high high
power that's with really fast wave
and above visible light and it has to be
relatively high power levels
none of the frequencies used for cell
phones have either the power nor the
freak high frequencies required to do
this as confirmed by countless studies
done for over 100 years
on the last page i just had some end
notes the higher the frequency the less
they penetrate walls and go over hills
every doubling of frequency effectively
halves the ability to penetrate walls
and go over hills at the same wattage
5g poses no more risk than the current
use for 4g and vastly less risk such as
there is any than when it was being used
for military and tv purposes
thank you representative for a
very comprehensive short term
schooling on frequencies
i i did have some more notes that didn't
make it into the presentation
5g is carried by radio waves transmitted
between antenna
or
or mast and your phone the waves travel
shorter distances through urban spaces
so it requires more transmitter mass
than previous technology closer to the
ground
radio waves their non-ionizing lacks
sufficient energy to break apart dna and
cause cellular damage
higher up the electromagnetic spectrum
well beyond cell phone frequencies clear
health risks from extended exposure the
sun could give you skin cancer x-rays
and gamma rays i didn't have anything
with that 5g uses more transmitters it
runs at lower power levels than 4g so it
equals lower level of radiation
part of the 5g spectrum falls under
microwave band generates heat and
objects through which they pass
maximum radio frequency level is so
small no temperature rise has been
observed to date and that's from
professor radney
rodney croft the advisor to the
international commission on non-ionizing
radiation protection
thank you uh
does anyone on this subcommittee have
any questions for the representative
in terms of her briefing
um
does anyone at this point i'd like to uh
open to our visitors to see if they have
any uh more to add in that information
we'll get the points in a minute i just
want to make sure that what was briefed
is understood by all and is i'm sure
it's
accurate but is there anything else that
they could add to it uh one minute
please representative kelly pitts you
have a question
well you're talking about adding to the
to the presentation and i made some uh
notes as i was going along
on the presentation so you want well a
couple of open discussion
a couple of things that i
made notes on is that
[Music]
if you block the 5g you block all cell
phones and most tv stations
and in my re my
research i found that not to be true
that some of the older cell phones will
not work and that that's something that
we haven't heard
and that people would have to uh
check to see what kind of you know how
many gigahertz your phone works on i'd
be darned if i could find out what my
phone works on probably
hot air
but it that that did not seem to be
correct
from the
information that i had
gleaned
there is such a thing as or and has been
studied
as radiation sensitivity and i remember
the studies that came out
years ago
that caution people about holding the
cell phones too close to your head
and this is going on a 4g and 3g
because there was a cola
coalition between cell phones uh people
who constantly use a cell phone and
brain tumors and that was a study that
was ongoing
and i do believe that they're still
ongoing even though it's being rolled
out
um
about
the human body not being an antenna i
don't know when i was a kid it was hold
the rabbit he is and we get reception
and we can get it so i think the human
body certainly is a conductor of
electricity and has can can do that and
i
was used as an antenna as a child
um
and a couple of other things uh
you were subject to constantly every
time you drove there's radiation all
around us we know that
we we our own friendly sun has radiation
and yes the sun will burn you
but then there are
effects that that some people have not
all people that are sensitive
that can be gleaned from just the normal
everyday radiation and one of the
factors in radiation in general is radon
and we're told to test
you know it's it's recommended that when
you buy a house you check it for radon
and also you will
so
there's so many things in my mind here
that
added to
what
what we're talking about
and the other one was the distance from
the source now we talked about the space
station the distance from the store
source makes the effects less
so i'm certainly not reaching out to the
space station
or trying to touch it i can't even
touch the light bulb in my house
so those are the things that i found
interesting
uh
and so and there are implications
and there are studies
and what i found is that some of this is
not
a hundred percent because none of the
scientists
seem to be
a hundred percent
with the information so that's my little
bit thank you
thank you representative and i would
agree um
there's a lot of unsettledness in this
technology right now
probably for some time to come i would
um i think it's important that we as a
subcommittee
understand the background and the
excuse me the wide variety of the
radiation that's around us
i believe for the purpose of this
bill um i think what we're focusing on
or what we should focus on is not so
much whether you can hold your phone to
your ear or not up it's the
uh any uh frequencies coming from the
actual towers
uh that are providing this medium uh to
whatever instruments has to choose 5g so
while i think it's very important that
we do understand this background
excellent presentation representative
dodder questions representative kelly
pitts um we need to understand all that
background so we can go forward and look
at the real specificness of tower and
how it could be interfering before i
go on to another question
is my understanding reading
i went to the frequently asked questions
of the fcc online provided very good
information is my understanding though
and also reading from the cita
presentation that uh
the technology of 5g uh the five seven
to five nine gigahertz i understand is
uh becomes uh ineffective after a
thousand feet
is what i i heard was being briefed by
the by the ctia so anything beyond a
thousand feet would i'm assuming would
render the 5g technology useless for for
what they have to use it for so that's
just what i read there
sarge uh i'm not gonna demote you to
sergeant representative partial
thank you thank you uh so much
representative thomas um and thank you
for the paper you said along um
from the european uh i i don't hack it
under the uh
it's a long acronym it is it is and i'm
horrible with acronyms i see too many
letters here yeah which warns me that my
very own
pride and joy in my kitchen my induction
cooktop is something that i should be
avoiding
um the difference there is i take that
risk on
and uh what we're talking about here is
we're imposing a risk on the broad
public
and my other question and this is
something that i've had in my back my
mind since this bill was first
introduced
if this technology is indeed
questionable enough
and potentially dangerous enough to
require setbacks
then why are we employing it at all when
we know that we have a job only half
done with 4g technology we have very
many dead spots in our in our state is
is always irritating to discover
i'm thinking that with limitations of 5g
and that's unfulfilled promise
we may be more wiser to this put the
whole thing on the back burner and
focus on 4g technology and continue that
the finishing that task
however i also do understand that we do
we have to seat a certain amount of
authority to the fcc
and lastly i'm still i'm going on her to
please forgive me
i know the fcc does uh
tend to carry a lot of um
well let's say uh
well i don't know how to say this uh the
the uh
chairs of the fcc are recruited from
lobbyists rather than scientific
community and i gotta say that i i am
concerned about that i'm concerned that
we are maybe are not getting the best
knowledge that we really require to make
such a decision i feel undereducated i
will say
and thank you for your time well thank
you representative um i i will say that
um
in ref uh uh it's i think you were
referring to the international
commission of on non-ionizing radiation
protection
they
their international body and my
understanding is that
the u.s does look at them for
specifications as well my understanding
reading some of the literature here
that
we
we even go beyond what they recommend
for
the specs i'll just i'll put it simply
they talk in terms of you know
power and amplifi amplitude and amperes
and and so forth but um i i will state
that just about everybody
uh be it uh
who or or this body here or other uh
health organizations
they classified just about everything in
terms of what kind of a carcinogenic
effect it would have on people
and i uh according to what i read
the
world health organization classifies um
this uh frequency this this technology
as a class 2b carcinogen or however you
pronounce it correctly yeah great now
that may
worry some people but i discovered that
many things are classified whether
they're low or high and this is
considered low level in fact the use of
talcum powder is put into the same
category as 2b
so it you know it and i believe that's
because no one can ever prove
conclusively that it does or doesn't but
evidence supports
low level and possible
so what's the risk factor low versus
high i think that's why they have it in
in that category although i do recognize
that you know some people do
they do have effects from this i mean
there's no question about it you know
people have effects
uh people have i know don't compare this
to allergens but in a similar way you
can be more sensitive to one allergy
versus another and it's
hell for some people i understand that
um that's that's my thing anyway uh
rip some callie pitts
i'll say tele
talcum powder the jury's out the the
awards have been made
but i i want to just say that there was
another issue
that
as far as rolling out 5g i couldn't get
an answer as to whether the money coming
from the federal government would be
used to
roll out 5g
exclusively
and the other was the companies behind
it now i know at t verizon they have
their
moniker on it
but who's the company behind it and
there was some question about one of the
companies
that is
rolling out 5g and that that company has
been banned in certain places because of
security reasons and they are the ones
behind the research and that are doing
this so that was another thing that kind
of put a little
dent in my brain and said wait a minute
if other countries are doing this
maybe we need to find out why and i
don't want to mention the name of the
company but they i believe hawaii has
banned
5g
and other other companies because of the
involvement with this particular company
so
i don't know and we have no control over
that
we
have seated that authority so i i just
don't know about this 5g
and also the warning to the people that
your phone may not work you may not be
able to make a 911 call and that that
scared me because even if you have a
deadline in your house if there's nobody
living there and you have
what was a landline
you could be able to plug into that line
or it used to be that you could make
911 but you could call 9-1-1 so if your
you couldn't call a
cell phone is disabled if you have an
older cell phone like i do
you may not be able to make a 9-1-1 call
in an emergency so there's a lot of
implications and the one thing that
really sparked my interest because all
of this i said well it's gonna happen
and we'll be up to 10 g by time i'm dead
was
what the faa
the problems the faa had
and saying wait a minute
this can
this radiation that nothing can get
through
in this report
can affect the altimeters and planes
um
makes me a little bit worried and that
they're now going to
have perimeters around airports so that
that worried me too so if it can affect
an airplane like that
how could it affect me
well i thank you for that and um
i would add though that from my reading
uh the faa is concerned about it ruling
out but it's it's i don't believe it's
because
of the actual um
what the the uh
effects of the of the wavelength would
cause
it's more because of the narrowness of
the bandwidth that lies between
the bandwidth they use for the
altimeter
settings uh on the airplanes and the uh
5g technology now my understanding
between five seven and five nine is
where the the new 5g technology falls
within
my understanding is that there is only a
0.3 gigahertz separation between the
bands
and that to me coming and having working
for 29 years
in the communications area
for acquisitions there that there that's
a very narrow ban for possible bleed
over and if you don't have good
insulation on some of these older planes
that there are there's a chance that it
could bleed over and affect the
altimeter reading uh particularly during
landing at low levels i believe that's
what the faa is concerned about that's a
different issue than what we're
discussing here though
it was a concern of mine but that's more
of a bandwidth separation issue
i think here we are also interested in
the the health
how it affects organic people
well all people are good some people may
not be organic but most most of them are
but um how it affects people and so
i rely on a lot of um
reports that are being put out
the world which we know the rest of the
world europe and particularly australia
are probably
the first ones to put any mandates up on
anything that they don't think is safe
or good and they haven't yet
they they have done studies on this and
they they claim that it's safe but i
safe is a relative term i understand
i don't i cannot deny that some people
are very sensitive to this type of
frequency at any bandwidth from from
radio to tv
uh even near airports with you know
radar and they can be affected just like
someone could be effective living in a
forest versus
urbanus or being affected in other ways
there certainly seems to be a
correlation
i don't see a whole lot of evidence
right now where there is a causation
which is a major factor but uh i'm
getting off track here just a little bit
representative kelly pitch you brought
up about the
9-1-1 since you brought that up i i
would like i i believe there's a
gentleman here from the department of
safety i'm sorry sir what was your name
again
mark doyle uh
he he may want to speak briefly about
the safety factory involving 9-1-1 and
other things if you would occur how how
would this affect how this bill affect
that
turn my con
i still have to get used to this
i thank you for um inviting me
representative thomas to speak to
that narrowly focused issue uh
representative kelly pittsburgh my name
is mark doyle i'm the director of the
division of emergency services and
communications overseeing 9-1-1 with the
department of safety
you spoke to
older cell phones and the technology
associated with all the cell phones on
the 3g
frequency bandwidth and
there are a lot of companies i know that
t-mobile sprint at t and verizon are all
phasing out their 3g networks this year
part and parcel to accommodate more
space and network allocation and
bandwidth toward the 5g rollout long
story short
what's going to happen with folks that
have those 3g capable cell phones right
now
is they will not be able to communicate
at all
even for the purpose of contacting 9-1-1
many folks had had and hung onto a lot
of those what we would call
decommissioned or inactive cell phones
because they
never had a subscription plan associated
with them but they were kicking around
at people's desks and whatnot and we
give them to their
um their children because they still
always had 911
associated with them meaning that even
though they didn't have a subscription
service you could still dial 9-1-1 every
cell phone is like that by the way the
problem associated with the old 3g
network is once the 3g network goes away
that capability goes away with it as
well so we've been trying to do our due
diligence to message out to folks that
if you have an older 3g phone 3g capable
phone
and it's on the 3g network to make sure
you connect with your your uh your
cellular digital network whomever that
carrier might be that telecom of that
lte carrier so that you can find out if
your phone's affected if it's only a 3g
phone and what you need to do to go
ahead and update that subscription so
you can get a phone that's capable of
dialing 9-1-1 either through the current
4g system or the
the scaling out of the 5g network
thank you for that question
you represent cali pitts thank you
for for for talking to that speaking to
that
uh
in some of the literature i read
it ford 3g was
also 4g
which is a more modern
i would think phone
and
i know the government's going to do
something to replace them or whatever
but still in an emergency
to that phone
seems to me to be a little bit i am
a little bit over the top and i
i helped put in the 911 network that's
how old i am
uh
so i i
i appreciate that that
people could have to buy another phone
or whatever
but that seems a little bit uh it's
scary to me that somebody needs to reach
out and call 9-1-1 and can't
so and not everybody's going to get that
message
i didn't have it
until i started digging through the
research so how do we deal with
that particular thing and is that going
to be do you know if that's going to be
everywhere or just in
proximity of these towers
and thank you for the question that's
actually a very good question my
understanding is when it comes to the
impact on 4g
is
i've not heard any of that in any of the
industry news that's been pushed out
again it's only the 3g capable cell
phones that are going to be impacted and
affected
so to your point how do we make sure
that we get the message out relative to
that issue
impacting folks that have the 3g phone
still and i understand there are
probably thousands or tens of thousands
of these still kicking around whether
they're being used actively or whether
they're in people's draws at home that
they've had that they've been having for
years and just never really activated
and have no subscription service we've
got to do our due diligence to assist
the telecoms the telecommunications
carriers lt network provisioners
and assist in getting that message to
all the folks in the state it's not just
to the state of new hampshire it's not
just to those telecommunication carriers
i mean this is something that's come
down from our own industry at 9-1-1 as
well as through the fcc the federal
communications commission to let folks
know that this is happening what i have
heard anecdotally is that a lot of the
carriers have sent messages out through
the mail or otherwise to the folks that
subscribe to those services right now
letting them know what the end of life
is for their 3g capable phone i think
verizon has theirs and their deadline is
the end of this year i believe sprint
and in
t-mobile are coming up in may and june
respectively and i think att is starting
their phasing out as early as february
so it's important that everybody does
their
their best effort to make sure that
people are aware that those phones are
going to go by the wayside and the
capabilities associated with them are
going to cease thank you
thank you
thank you very much uh does anyone hack
you mrs doyle uh if you're standing by
here for the rest of the meeting it'd be
great if if if some questions come
you're certainly welcome to stay and
thank you for the invite representative
thomas i appreciate that thank you thank
you so much
uh before we move on
before we move on i uh is there anyone
here that represents ctia or the
industry
at all
i'm looking at the testimony from
bethany cooley from ctia
um
and
at one point here they they say that um
and i'll read this quote
it says um
let's see acting responsibly scientists
engineers continue to research rf
exposure including rf exposure with 5g
technology for example studies have
shown that 5g communication which will
take
advantage of small cell network
architecture rests in more base stations
operating at lower point
power levels
goes on to say that further a recent
study demonstrated that 5g antenna
densification
does not increase the level of exposure
in contrast to a very popular belief on
the contrary antenna densification does
not change the exposure levels for the
majority of the population while at base
station proximity a huge radiation
decrease is experienced when more base
stations are deployed in the same
territory
i was hoping if anyone here could maybe
speak to that or have any knowledge on
that
if you
could
representative honor um i i don't i just
i have a stack of the testimony that we
heard and it's just down the hall i'm
just going to run and get it
okay
yes state your name and who you
represent i'm kent chamberlain and i'm
uh
from durham new hampshire and i served
on the commission we have two other
people who served on the commission
behind me so
oh okay sorry about that
but uh before i start i should say that
tell a little bit about who i am because
this seems to be a contentious issue
not contentious because the science
isn't clear but it's contentious because
there's a lot at stake
in particular money-wise so i'm ken
chamberlain culture okay and
before i joined the commission and while
i served on the commission i was chair
of the department of electrical and
computer engineering at the university
of new hampshire
and the reason i was asked to serve on
the commission was because of my
background in electromagnetics and
radiofrequency engineering so i've got a
lot of experience and with the the
questions and the comments that were
made earlier and i can certainly address
them
but what i'd like to start off with oh
and i also should mention is that i'm
yeah i've come out of the ivory tower
many many times in my 40-year career
i've worked with 25 research sponsors
from industry and government agencies in
fact i worked on it's called project 54
that deals with first responders and
make sure that they have the
communications they need so i'm very
sensitive to not only the needs of
industry but also the needs of first
responders and people who need to
communicate via things like 9-1-1
so i'm coming to you now as a citizen
i'm unpaid
for what i do so i don't have any vested
interest in what i'm going to tell you
today
i think a starting point would be to say
that you know you talked a lot about
frequencies and this is something of
course we looked at on the commission
remember the commission met on a regular
basis throughout the year and we did a
lot of studying on our own
and so some things
and this discussion of frequencies came
up very early on
and the bottom line for that is that we
found that the frequencies the all the
frequencies that you named for digital
communication are harmful now it's very
likely that some frequencies are going
to be more harmful than others but it's
really the the research done so far has
not parsed that out
so all of the frequencies that are used
for digital communication starting with
500 megahertz on up
do have adverse physiological effects
and they've been very thoroughly
documented in the literature
so that's the first point i want to make
we also found as you can probably tell
for those of you who have looked at the
conclusions of our final report we found
that exposure to radiation does cause
significant harm
and this is cell phone type radiation
so we've looked at the epidemiology in
fact it's pretty clear i don't know why
there uh a link was sent to you about a
video that i we came up with our
rationale for
setting a 500 meter setback
and the reason is and you do this
several ways one is you can look at
people living near cell towers and find
out how their health your adverse health
effects for those people and then
plot that as a function of the distance
they live from the cell towers now
that's been done in 10 studies and an
eight of the ten of those studies it
showed that at about 500 meters you're
going to start not seeing adverse
effects from living near a cell tower
so the fact that i can even talk about
that to begin with the fact that
mortality rates drop off when you look
at people the distance people live from
a cell tower that in itself is a good
indication a strong indication that
they're the the living nearest cell
tower isn't good for you and that is the
focus of our legislation the legislation
being proposed
if you have one cell tower right in your
backyard you're far more likely to die
of things like cancer but there are many
other things too cancer is just one
issue
what happens when you're exposed to
radiation the type of radiation that
we're talking about cell phone type
radiation is that there is what's
referred to as oxidative radiation
so it was talked about earlier was
ionizing radiation and that's where the
photons the individual photons have
enough energy to knock electrons off of
atoms and cause mutations we know about
that that's what causes things like skin
cancer i know firsthand about that i had
to go to the dermatologist to get some
of that burned off so we know about that
and we've known about it for a long time
but what it seems to be somewhat newer
is the fact that it's radiation like the
radiation you get from your cell phone
causes oxidative radiation oxidative
you've heard these terms before um free
radicals that comes from oxidizing
radiation that's why we eat antioxidant
foods and take supplements to lower our
oxidation is that we don't want those
free radicals in our body and that's
exactly what cell phone radiation cell
phone type radiation wireless radiation
does to your body
so
what we've found is that if you move
away from the transmitter if you had
remember this only pertains to future
installations but if you're at 500
meters or more from a cell phone
transmitter you're less likely it's very
likely that you won't experience any
adverse health effects at all
so
that is the basic finding the science so
i mentioned that we did it by looking at
the epidemiology first that is look at
the health outcomes of people living
near towers we also looked at what the
outcomes were in laboratory experiments
so in the laboratory you can very
carefully adjust what the exposure
levels are for for whatever it is that
you're studying and find out set kind of
a lower level that where you say that
below this level adverse effects don't
happen so we identified what that signal
level was
and then found out how far from a
typical cell tower you would have to go
to achieve that level of radiation
turns out that both ways of making this
calculation came up with the same basic
result they weren't exact but they were
very very close and that is 500 meters
or
1640 feet
so we came up we have a very solid
rationale scientific based rationale for
saying
you shouldn't put towers closer than 1
640 feet from places where people live
work and recreate
so by doing that by following what is
asked for in this legislation we will go
a long way in protecting the people of
new hampshire from
a type of exposure that can be pretty
severe
uh thank you mr emma i have a question
before
uh representative mcgee um
so where i was reading where
the 5g technology i used 5g because i
know it's that's not frequency but the
the 5g technology i read becomes
ineffective at around a thousand feet
uh now it begs the question do you mean
it's ineffective in terms of um
being able to be useful for
communications or is does it mean
ineffective in terms of it has no effect
on anybody or anything i don't know
anyone here that can answer that
question but if that being the case and
we were to put this at 500 meters uh you
you would effectively shut down
all of that type of communication
uh in in those areas and particularly
around
hospitals and businesses that rely
heavily on faster data would that not be
correct
there are a few things that should be
mentioned here one is that 5g is more or
less a marketing term there is no recipe
for 5g and in fact there are a lot of 5g
transmitters that do have nothing to do
with the higher frequencies they're
using the same frequencies as 4g
and that's one reason that we didn't
make an exclusion for only the higher
frequencies that's something that could
be looked at later but what you could
conceivably do if we made that exception
for 5g now is simply move
essentially the 4g towers put them into
these little small cells and radiate at
the same level as they're radiating now
which would cause greater exposure
there's another statement that i'd like
to make and that regard involves 5g and
it's something that was said earlier is
the claim that radiation levels go down
when you put in 5g and that's not the
case
5g piggybacks on top of 4g
so when you add 5g you add to the total
radiation and this has been shown in
cities where 5g has been installed there
are
studies that go on where people measure
the radiation level in various cities
this is an ongoing effort and i can give
you links to that so when you go to a
city that has 4g only and below you're
going to have certain radiation levels
as you move through the city but when
you go to a city that has 5g installed
your radiation levels go up
and what we discovered on the commission
is that radiation is like smog if you
will like air pollution that you have
background levels and at certain points
they start rising and rising and people
start getting sick from it and that's
why some people who aren't electro
hypersensitive now become electro hyper
sensitive as they're exposed to
increasing levels of background
radiation
thank you i'll allow myself one
follow-up before moving on um so uh i
think the quote that i read uh previous
to q coming on and talked in terms of
densification which i believe it's as
you put more antennas together your
overall effects might go down i i will
say that from my experience um
working a bit in the
military
acquisition field
there was a lot of concern when you put
too many antennas together that their
overall effects
go down because there's a lot of
interference and scattering so the
effects go down would that not be the
same type of technology
this
in this way if you put two main tenants
together
that you actually decrease
their their power
that that flies in the face of the
physics that i know
and that is that it's at times there
will be cancellation certainly but at
other times there's going to be
reinforcements so you're going to have a
signal now that varies rapidly and
hugely
in the final analysis the total exposure
is going to be the sum of all
transmitters of all radiation sources
okay sure
mcgee
thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
um as i've been listening to the
information that's being presented in
terms of the amount of of radiation
that's being emitted uh that we're that
we're discussing
um
we've got mega
megahertz and also
gigahertz and those are two very
different things in terms of uh amounts
and when i just heard you say that we we
have used the science in order to
determine a calculation of what would be
a safe distance
i'm wondering what level of hurts you
are applying to the technology so that
we could maybe understand how these
equations were calculated
absolutely and and i can go through them
with you right now
but like said it's not the hurts
as long as we're talking about digital
radiation
you know 600 megahertz and above
it seems you know the evidence shows
they are are all
all harmful but what matters is the
exposure level and that would be the
milliwatts or watts per meter squared
so you have a radiation source you could
even consider light bulb it's radiating
down and so how much energy is coming
out of that light bulb or how much of
that is striking me
it's going to be the watts per area
multiplied times the area that's being
exposed so it's the radiation level or
the power level that determines what's
harmful that's we're finding
so we there i can give you numbers we're
thinking that the lower limit would be
500 microwatts
per meter squared now there's some
people who would still be affected by
that the people who are electro
hypersensitive and by the way that is a
real thing it's recognized by the
americans with disabilities act and with
medic by medicare so it's a real thing
and so people that are electrosensitive
at 500 microwatts per meter squared
they're still going to be
feeling it so our legislation the
proposed legislation won't protect
everybody absolutely but it will make
them you know provide them with some
protection against the more severe
effects that might occur at higher
exposure levels
thank you
representative white
so you you mentioned a second ago about
americans uh there's a law that
recognizes
these
what what is there in terms of research
though
that recognizes these uh disabilities
people that are more sensitive to
electromagnetic radiation and things
like that
i'm thinking the work by martin paul i
mean there is a whole trove of
information and maybe this is something
if you don't mind i'd like to say about
the commission is where we got our
information that would answer a question
like the one you're answering are you
asking right now
one of my jobs on the commission
was to look at the quality of journals
that were being used to to to get our
provider information
you'll hear from the telecommunications
industry and remember they don't like
our our
pronouncement that the there is harm in
radiation exposure so what they do what
they have claimed is that all articles
that show harm from radiation exposure
are from what they call fringe journals
and they are cherry picked
and that's absolutely not true and so
one of my jobs on the commission was to
look at that and evaluate whether or not
there were fringe journals and the
reason i was picked for that job is
because i am a former associate editor
for ieee transactions on attendance and
propagation so it's a major scientific
publication and i was an associate
editor so i was given that task is to
look at the articles that showed harm
and determine if they were from quality
journals
and i can just tell you shortly and in
short terms now that yes absolutely high
highly credible journals with the
editors the the
authors of the journals the reviewers
were all from recognized universities
and so the information was rock solid so
there are many articles that do show the
adverse effects that i'm talking about
right now and those are what we looked
at and there are hundreds if not
thousands of articles showing that from
reputable journals so yeah this is not
something new uh showing that the harm
the harm that's recognized and has been
recognized by the ada for a while it is
well known in the science
did i answer your question
i think so thank you
representative kelly pitts
can you tell me uh
is the uh
report from the commission
the complete report available anywhere
yes it's online uh representative abrami
didn't feel like uh you should he should
hand out the 400 targets
on what website
i i would really
miss
chair i would really like i mean in lou
that we don't have a phone book to read
anymore i really would like to read the
report and see if i can make
more heads in the tales of it and and
see again your sources
uh and look at that so i no objection to
going online
of course i don't have 5g so it'll take
me four days
but
i
i just um would like to know what
website that's available on
yes
representative
this is the beginning part of the report
reports 390 pages long 290 pages long
created by a commission in new hampshire
a lot of that's minutes a lot of that's
all the references that
dr chamberlain is talking about we have
thousands of references of from science
you should be talking about
so but well it's in the report you know
romney could if you're going to speak a
long time would you like mike please
i'll share
go ahead
sorry i i thought you had a brief
statement that's what i did too
[Laughter]
i guess i can't help myself we spent a
lot of time on this as a commission 14
months
we we've accumulated thousands of papers
as
dr chaiman is talking about that are all
referenced in
the report and dependencies of the
report
and matter of fact in the body of the
they are linked if you so we if you get
the report you can when we talk about
something we link it to specific papers
that relate to it so
but for a committee like this it's it's
a it's an overwhelming task to go
through all the science we did
and i'm just saying we did the homework
for
this moment we did the homework for this
kind of a bill to be brought forward
and you know
it was it was very difficult in the
initial meeting to express all that we
know we appreciate the time today
this is giving us a chance to in a more
informal setting
to try to get through some of the signs
to you and i and as i as i step down
from here i'd like you to bring i like
to bring ken wells to sit next to him
because and you all know ken from being
a science and tech guy
and ken was on the commission as well
uh but he's got a background in physics
as well so we've got the two physics
guys here that could could shed some
light on this yeah represent kelly pitts
i need a follow-up i asked a very simple
question
where can i reference this report can
you give me a website
i'm going to send
i'm going to send a link to the com i
don't have it it's it's a long link so i
will send a link to the to the chair or
to the i'll send a link to i'll send a
link to you and the rest of the
committee as well
thank you
okay thank you
um
i do have a question um well uh
i guess for anyone that was on on the
commission i i understand there
that there is that there was a minority
report on that commission report is
there anyone here that could speak to
the minority report at all
not that i see let me explain the
minority report that's the way
commissions work
we when i i filed a bill to create the
5g commission so i said well let's have
let's have
let's have the people from the industry
so
ctia who you're referencing um
beth cooley
who is
the lobbyist i wanted a scientist
i wanted a scientist from the ctia to be
on the committee but there wasn't so i
thought we would have a dialogue in this
committee probably naively
thinking that we could come to some
terms
as to the issue
so she was an honorary of course of
course she was going to be the minority
she's representing the industry
then we had i also requested that the
bia
find me a scientist business industry
association of new hampshire
and
they couldn't find a scientist
because we have a lot of high-tech
companies here i wanted somebody with
background and radio frequency and all
that
and uh so
dave gervais who most of us know
so i can't find anybody but i'll i'll
sit on it
but i mean after the first meeting dave
for dave you know because we really got
into the science and his eyes were
rolling you know like wow
but dave
dave was
never came to the meetings until the
very end and was one of the two in the
minority report
and then of course there was senator
gray
who had some legitimate arguments
but those were the three people who
voted for the minority report two of
them you know and and and dave basically
represents businesses who don't
understand the detail of this don't
understand the science of this
and
you know i i i love day i mean i work
with dave all the time so i'm just not
disparaging mark but
and again
the
this
we're here to say that the science is
there
uh we're we're trying to find a way of
taking a first step by this bill to do
something we'd love to work with the
science and tech committee here
to
to if if this is in the bill that you
like
that we
we create uh some kind of a
subcommittee of this group to continue
looking at this
i can bring in experts of science like
dr chamberlain uh high quality uh people
who understand this again it took me a
while to figure this out too i'm an
engineer
but you know through the we brought in a
lot of experts into this committee from
around the country uh around the country
and this is no small this is not just
new hampshire and
you know
all eyes are on this
you you all got hundreds of emails
from around the country and around the
world
on this topic
because no one's listening
no one's listening
someone mentioned
that the fcc is a captive
a captive agency
absolutely no question
everybody in the fcc came from the
industry their job is in science their
job is to allocate bandwidth that's what
they do they allocate bandwidth
but
but they rely on the fda
but the fda
doesn't do
much of their own science they may
review some papers whatever
but we as a commission little new
hampshire tried to get the the fcc tried
to get the fda to answer our questions
our specific questions
and this refers to a website
oh good we had very specific questions
so was the science that you have
that says this isn't harmful show us the
science
and we got
then we then we even tried the
environmental protection agency they
used to have a role
years ago before 1996 before the
telecommunication act of 1916 1996
and that when we reached out to them
they said not our job
we don't have any funding for this not
our mission but they are probably the
most equipped to to really weigh in on
this
so
i know
this bill is really putting a lot on
your shoulders here
and i'm saying okay maybe maybe we pass
this bill maybe we don't pass this bill
but i don't want this dialogue to die
i i think we need to somehow
craft something that
we can keep this going and
it's an important topic
and again i'm not i'm not
i'm not the kind of guy that is um
you know
a warrior when it comes to
these kind of
most things i don't i'm not the guy i'm
out there doing this but after i learned
and i sat through the commission for 14
months
i said wow
there's something here
and
so those those are so my thoughts and i
i do wish you hit from
former representative
wells as well because he has so much
interesting insights as well to share
with you
today
okay a question uh representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
you know this is really difficult
because you like you said we got emails
from everywhere from all over and
there's always two sides to every story
so we hear from some scientists that say
people are getting sick and it's bad we
got to stop this other scientists are
saying that they're they're it's not
it's inconclusive and you can't prove it
and
my thoughts are all going haywire well
earlier when the chairman was talking
about talcum powder reminding me of a
workshop i went to about the toxic world
we live in there's toxins everywhere
there's chemicals in everything it's in
our food it's in mattresses it's in
carpets it's in our clothing it's like
people are hypersensitive i mean how far
do we go
um we are sympathetic to people that are
that are sense are hypersensitive to
everything and
we can't
say with absolute certainty that the
technology is what's making them sick
you know the jury's still out on that
because there's always conflicting
science but one thing we do know and
that we cannot forget is that
the industry is never going to support
the passage of this bill and it's going
to halt future investments in new
hampshire
so it's very very difficult let's hear
all this i don't think they're going to
abandon this market
again all we're asking for is that
that we're i think in my opening
comments in the hearing was simple i
said
we all love our cell phones we all want
them but do we need to watch a
full-length movie
while we're walking down the street
i mean that's what we're talking about i
mean
uh
you know we're we're all for safe
science safe
science and that's all we're talking
about
and and by the way let's not confuse
broadband there's some confusion and
with with this
broadband is we're all for optical uh
cable you know optical um
and
but yes it's part a small part of the
the whole discussion of this but
it's not it's up you know what we're
doing in that front is a whole nother
another story as well
representative partial
thank you again representative and thank
you for um spinning this bill um
you just mentioned broadband and that
was piqued my interest because i just
became familiar with a term called
mobile broadband
which uh
they're claiming speeds with uh f5 up to
uh 50 megabytes per second
however an article from last year the
washington post
said that the actual
speeds that one
can expect are far lower than that
i've seen nothing to
contradict that
so again i mean i would love to see us
be able to have driverless cars and all
that some future point
uh right now
i got stranded in nelson a couple weeks
back because my electric car died here
and i could not call my garage because i
could not get cell coverage
i'm just again i mean uh
warner i don't see this as the end of
cellular technology if we do not
incorporate 5g but if i'm wrong please
correct me
and another question that you had
earlier about uh cto2 questions ctia
they claim that
aviation
uh emissions will not be any greater
with a higher density
is it the equivalent of building more
swimming pools
and saying that
let me say this some
we can build more swimming pools
and cluster them closer together
and one swimming pool may not affect the
quality of water and then on a swimming
pool but children are going to get
wetter
um i mean is that a workable and an
allergy
actually i'm not sure how to answer that
one but just the you know the more and
let's put it this way instead of
swimming pools let's call it smokers
if one of us were in this room smoking
we would have a level of toxin pollution
but if we were all smoking chain smoking
that level would come up so the more
smokers there are the more radiation
sources there are the more sources of
pollution will affect us and have
negative effects on us is that a fair
analogy
from what you're saying i would ask
again if if the person from ctia was
here i would ask her to if she could uh
explain it another way then because it
sounds like it and and i and it does
answer my question though yes
same question in a different manner
from what i was reading i'm not sure if
it meant that the effects would be any
less or more but i think it was talking
in terms of
power
is it possible that if you combine
several antennas closer together that
they wouldn't need as much power
to
to have coverage as they would if they
had lesser antennas is that a fair
question i think that's it's a fair
question and i can see where if you
distribute you have distributed antennas
yes you could then use lower power
total depend there there are a lot of
caveats here it's how you implement it
but if you had one that was only
transmitting when there was somebody
that was communicating with that
particular tower i could see that that
would be the case but please keep in
mind that where they've made the
measurements that hasn't been the
reality
where they've made measurement places
with 5g have a higher background
radiation than those places that don't
have 5g
so
i i've heard some of these arguments but
they don't really make sense
and there's one other issue that i
wanted to address and then with some
somebody talking about coverage area and
remember that my a lot of my career has
been spent modeling propagation where
can you get signals if you put a tower
here here or here
so you can provide coverage so if you're
stranded in your car that's because
there wasn't a tower nearby obviously
and it's a question of what markets the
the cell industry wants to maintain and
where they want to put antennas
as a radio frequency engineer somebody
who's modeled electromagnetics i can
tell you you can do it it may be it's a
function of cost it may cost you more to
put in that tall tower that gives you
that broader coverage area and provides
lower exposure to individuals
but it can be done and it's just a
matter of cost in most cases
i'm sorry represent partial you could
ask your follow-on question but before
that i would advise you to carry a power
pack with you in your car wherever you
go just just in case you know we all
make mistakes and i made a big one on
that one i'm not hit you know i'm not
ashamed to admit it
um
i don't have this information at hand uh
but i've heard that the current
commission at the fcc the five appointed
uh commissioner well i guess one is
vacant now but the four seats um
equally democrat and republican
um
they all are drawn from
ctia background and where they have
served as lobbyists within that industry
i don't know if that's true or not do
you have any information on that i don't
have the current information but i
suggest that people look at the the
harvard report and you can find that
hardwood report by googling harvard
fcc and captured and they go through
exactly who's been serving and when
and that is the case and they they
equate what's going on with with the
telecommunications industry now and cell
phone exposure they equate that to the
tobacco industry
is that of course tobacco probably some
of them still claim it doesn't cause
cancer
but
the it seems like the telecommunication
industry is following that playbook and
that's according to this harvard report
so yeah a lot of the people running the
fcc are from industry
thank you represent kelly pitts
i want to follow up on something since
we were doing swimming pools and brought
my mind to pigs
you said that four
5g piggybacks on 4g so if you
don't roll out the 5g as comprehensively
as
it's they want to do it
would it stop
or would it inhibit
um
eliminating
dead zones in new hampshire if we
stopped that would we then cause a
problem or exacerbate a problem
with quote unquote dead spots
so i'm sorry if we turned off 5g
if we stopped the rollout or somehow
inhibited the rollout of 5g
would that inhibit us or stop us
from answering the problem of dead zones
and dead spots
in the state of new hampshire
so i mean my answer would be no
you would have to i mean assuming that
you would use 4g technology to fill in
those gaps no that wouldn't be a problem
by the way 5g is mostly for data
4g 3g is for telecommunications talking
to people
any more questions for these two
gentlemen before we go to
the honorable
wells
representative
have any other states span 5g
okay
this is what's going on in the country
communities are trying to do something
about it
but it's it's a hard battle
trying to
through ordinances to try to
limit where the antennas are
not not ban it but limit it
again
backtrack one thing 5g is a concept we
talked about a marketing concept
each one of the companies has their own
strategy
now
what
what the new wrinkle was millimeter
waves okay we went up further up the
up up the uh spectrum
but as as the chair mentioned millimeter
waves don't travel very far
so by about 1000 maybe a thousand feet
or something like that
so
if we go 5g in that route using
small cell antennas
those antennas would have to be spaced
every
200 200 yards
on telephone poles
in front of your house
that's what got me going i said to
myself do i really want one of those in
front of my house probably not
but we're powerless because of the 1996
act
i say to myself forget about the health
forget about all that
i mean
we as americans
are beholden to a 1996 act and standards
that have not changed
since 1996
they just re-upped their standards in
and guess what
the
joe kennedy's
group
children's defense and
the
environmental health trust
both sued and i told i mentioned this in
the last in my presentation
and the
court of appeals in dc
uh circuit
said that that the fcc's
reissuing of the same standards
was arbitrary and capricious they did
not review the science
that and that's what the court said and
that something to me was a big flag you
know maybe we're onto something here
this came out last summer last august
now where the court of appeals were
weighing in on a federal agency
not doing what they were supposed to do
in
publishing
regulations
and but understand that those those
standards have not changed
and someone had mentioned
about power density yeah you know we
talked about power it really is
ultimately about power density coming
out of the antennas
and we we considered that in the
commission saying well maybe we
we can say you know let's measure the
power densities around because
who's testing all this stuff nobody
nobody
that's the problem who's who's
overseeing this stuff
certainly not the federal government you
see trucks out there measuring no do you
see the state we're not measuring
so
so that that's that's the that's the
number the thing but
we
our country has the highest standards
in reverse really the lowest standards i
mean the highest
number i forget the number now
the 10 watts per meter squared thank you
as acceptable
other developed countries
don't have that much lower standards and
why is that you know it's like
we can go we can go country to country
even countries like india have have
lower standards and russia have lower
standards
so
but yes power density we say well
one of one of the one of the things we
had talked about in the commission is
well why don't we just establish that we
would we would measure the state would
measure
you know each around
different areas as to what the densities
are of of the rf radiation
of the the amounts
understand that there's a compounding
effect
depending on where these antennas are
of of this radiation
there's all sorts of stuff that we
talked about in the community you know
we talked about the modulating issues
we talked about
about the uh
the uh the
co what's that called the cone
but there's there's
yeah the patterns in the now and the
pulse signals that these these are
pulsing waves
uh they're not continuous waves they
pulse when they're pulsing they're at
higher intensity
uh so this is all the stuff that's out
there that we need to get our arms
around
so we we chose to go with the distance
from new antennas
and not the power
power and i but i will agree that you
know we should get our arms around the
power density
uh
what's an acceptable level of power
density of all the antennas in an area
because because one tower interacts with
another tower it's you know
and understand and this
um
i wanted to say one more thing this came
as a quote from the ctia
right here
so saying today which was last year or
two years ago 154 000 cell towers today
and this is a quote from the ctia
there are 154 000 cell towers today to
meet growing mobile data demands and win
the race to 5g
projects
we will need to install hundreds of
thousands of small cells in the next few
years
sap global market intelligence projects
more than 800 000
small cells need to be deployed will be
deployed by 2026.
wow 154 towers to 200 to 800 000.
not to mention
what spacex is setting up
every
every day or every
week or two
they're sending up
hundreds of satellites there's going to
be over 100 000 or so satellites beaming
down
uh signals
so
i i don't know call me crazy
i i just think we need to pause and i
wish this was really being discussed at
the national level where it should be
being discussed
but we can't even get through the
congressmen and senators
follow the money
the one beauty thing about new hampshire
is
we don't get paid off
we don't
especially in the house there's 400 of
us uh
no lobbyists have called me
uh
from the other side none which is good
uh they know my position but
uh
i i'm just saying you know if you read
the whole report
that we produced
we have very rational
conclusions very rational um
solutions
you know from
warnings
you know and by the way this is only
about i mean the commission we did we
started out as 5g commission but we
quickly discovered we can't talk about
5g without talking about 3g and 4g it's
all it's all it's all linked together
and and then you can't talk about att
versus verizon because they have
different strategies
so you can't really put your hand around
it we talked about
intended what's inside those antennas
how are they configured uh i think
representative wells maybe that's a good
segue to him because he's he's the one
who really seems to know a lot about
that as well as
is dr chamberlain you know uh thank you
uh representative that is a good segue i
i think i would like to hear from the
honorable ken wells right now and thank
you i'd like to be done with this by
noontime so if there's anyone else that
wishes to speak on this
uh please uh
if you give us a card just over that we
have a copy of your name and
and so forth not
trying to make it a formality but we do
need to copy that down represent partial
yes
no turn it on
that would help thank you
um
will uh this representative be available
for questions later on we've also as
part of this bill there's a
self-reporting registry
and
i'll be honest i don't have any
particular ideas on that but i would
love to hear
how that would work and i would hate
that to get pushed aside i understand
that you have a lot of issues to address
here and i just
would hate to see that forgotten in the
course of discussing the science and the
politics
thank you
mr chair uh
from a bill standpoint i'm willing to
set that one aside
so we can focus on in terms of the bill
and uh
and go forward because there's enough
concerns about that in terms of how it
would work that i would say
amend that out and let's just focus on
the cell tower
yes thank you um yeah i'd like to start
out just by by clarifying some of the
definitions here we started out with the
commission looking at the 5g health
effects but we discovered quickly that
that 5g is not a physical description
it's a marketing term it means new and
improved okay and what we're talking
about here let's not talk about 5g and
4g or broadband
internet what we're talking about here
specifically is radio frequency
radiation okay and radio frequency
radiation
can hurt you now um thank you
representative knotter for your
very good introduction where you talked
about wattages and frequency ranges of
the band of the spectrum
but there are a couple of things that
you left out and one is it's not just
the power of the transmitter it's how
close it is okay and that that is what
has uh a very large effect on living
systems my background is in biochemistry
and biophysics
and so we we heard in that introduction
about thermal
effects and ionizing radiation but
radio frequency will also
affect biomembrane potentials and what i
mean by biomembranes these are the
membranes involved in your nervous
system they're the membranes involved in
reproduction like you know you know when
a when an uh when an ovum is is
fertilized by one sperm it changes the
voltage on the outside of the thing so a
second one can't get in ordinarily
photosynthesis uses membrane potentials
birds and bees use it for navigation
it's involved in blood clotting and it's
involved in oxidation as
dr chamberlain
mentioned we don't even have to give up
any of the advantages of communication
and high speed stuff
when we give up a high energy high
density radio frequency because
optical fiber optics and light
transmitted stuff is a hundred times
faster so the the vested interests here
are the people who are making and
selling radio frequency stuff
um
we could talk a little bit about um
uh the the distance and the
densification
um
it's a it's a well-known thing in
physics gauss's law tells you how much
the field dissipates as you back away
from a source okay and if it was a
spherical distribution same in all
directions you know the bigger that
bubble gets uh the more its area
increases and the same amount of energy
is spread over a larger area
however
with this type of application you can
shape the the shape of the emissions the
same way you can shape the light emitted
from a street light you know the light
doesn't go straight up in outer space
you reflect it back down where you want
it now if you're going to do a
communications network you would reflect
it out as much as you could into a
horizontal cookie shape right
in that case the amount of energy is uh
going to be dissipated over the
circumference of that circle
okay 2 pi r
so if you are one football field away
from a standard transmitter
antenna
you would get a certain amount of energy
we'll just call it you know a bucket
load of energy
if you had
evenly spaced antennas that same one
football field
apart there would be about six of them
in the circle around you you would get
six times as much exposure from those
if you have another circle that's two
football fields away 12 of them will fit
there and you get another six okay so
this is the thing about densification if
you have more and more and more and more
of these things and and uh
representative abrami was just talking
about 150 000 more of these things uh if
you're talking about the density that 5g
providers are advertising you know
they're advertising putting one down
every hundred meters okay um that's
that's a very large grid and if you
think of a city if you had one every
hundred meters in a checkerboard it's a
huge number of of antennas
they also advertise that you can
concentrate the field at a particular
point and the way you do that is these
antennas operate independently they have
an internet connection and they can
delay the signal so that uh they can
steer the beam okay and if you do that
you can get many many many times higher
energy at a certain location than you
even get at the transmitter right at the
antenna
the difficulty is that there are three
parameters here that we we need to worry
about and and a couple of them uh
representative knotter talked about the
frequency as the frequency goes up the
amount of energy increases
uh the
uh the wattage of the
transmitter how bright the light bulb is
is another thing
and the third thing is the distance and
it turns out we can't control the first
two because those are controlled by
software and you know how dieselgate
worked right they they fiddled the
software so they got it to do stuff that
they weren't allowed to do
you wouldn't be able to stop them from
doing that and i don't even think that
the companies that sell
5g
know what they're buying because they're
not manufacturing the stuff
we certainly don't want people who
manufacture
these things to put
capabilities in there that would expose
us to more of this
this radiation
dave duvet who was mentioned
representing bia said that the power
level of the transmitter is a hard
number to nail down and that's because
the if the engineers want to do it they
can uh make it perform within this
little envelope when it's being uh
reviewed and tested
and expanded to that in use same way
dieselgate worked
so we need to be careful about what we
allow in new hampshire and the only
thing we really have the only tool we
have is to make sure those antennas are
not so close together
and
one of my hobbies is auto racing and you
can get hurt in auto racing and you look
at
what is the most likely bad thing that
could happen and then you
change your equipment and you take
safety precautions to make sure that bad
thing can't happen it's called the
precautionary principle and i think that
we should exercise a precautionary
principle here and uh and limit how
close those antennas can be to each
other and also to uh people
and so um i'd be happy to uh answer any
further questions you have
uh
thank you uh
um
the honorable wells it's nice having you
back in here again um
i don't want to cut your uh your time
short i do have a question uh if you uh
if we feel like we have to stay later
you
you may stay and come back
um
what
and i don't think there's anyone here
from the from the
provider area to answer this question
but perhaps you can
is there a
minimum distance that
antennas
need to be placed in order for them to
work with the data stream that that they
want to project in other words uh they
is there a distance of say maybe 10 feet
20 feet 100 feet 500 feet that they
can't be placed any closer because it it
wouldn't serve their purpose to transmit
data my what i'm i'm getting at is i'm
trying to figure out from from a
technological point of view what's the
minimum distance that they that they
can't get any closer to otherwise
they're just not going to work yeah well
as you mentioned when you get antennas
very very close together you get all
kinds of interference reflections off of
buildings and things like that which
cause your signal to get garbled if you
imagine being in a room with three or
four radios going right it'd be hard to
understand what was going on even though
it get it's getting louder right and
what we want to do is we want to make
sure that that signal doesn't get so
loud that it hurts people okay
because
as you get them very close together it
needs to get louder in order for the the
signal to get through so there's a
diminishing return
the other limitation that was mentioned
though is that
the higher frequency you go up
uh the more oxygen
uh in the environment absorbs the signal
especially water vapor remember that
we're three quarters water we absorb
this stuff too right and it's it's not
good for us in fact it's not just the
oxygen but it's all those other you know
biomembranes and things like that
will participate in what's called
resonance
resonance is matching the frequency of
some
something that can jiggle around a
molecule say and um
an analogy i think of is you know when
when we were little kids and we learned
how to swing a playground swing we
discovered you couldn't go like this
because it wouldn't go you had to match
the frequency right when the frequencies
match that wave gets bigger and bigger
and bigger until something breaks okay
and forms free radicals does some
oxidation does some other sort of side
reactions that are that are not good for
us those are the frequencies that happen
in this millimeter wave range
starting at around 600 mil megahertz and
coming all the way up to the to you know
one to three millimeters which are the
the frequencies that the military has
developed into a weapon it certainly
does harm so um those are the things
that we want to
uh we want to attenuate
if we need to have wireless
communication that has higher data
transmission rates we should look at
light laser um it's much better safer
technology
having sunlight shine on you
is generally not too bad
which brings me to one other point a lot
of these studies particularly older ones
treat radiation as if it was a toxic
chemical and they they
establish what they call an sar which is
how many watts per kilogram
that's irrelevant okay if you're talking
about how much sunburn you're going to
get from radiation it's watts per square
meter okay and so much of the of the
inconclusive reports that you go out
there are are using the wrong unit and
so if you look at the stuff that is
based on watts per square meter it's
fairly um it's fairly convincing because
there it's not just humans uh that are
affected by this uh very good study out
of germany that looked at tree growth
and the side that faces towards the tree
um is damaged okay and it doesn't matter
how it's oriented north south and all
that stuff they did a huge number of
trees and examined these things and the
trees are damaged uh by being uh uh
close to a an antenna
and the damage lessens as you get
further away we know that if you put a
cell phone that's on in a beehive it'll
kill the hive right um you know so birds
and bees pollinators
absolutely crucial are affected by this
stuff so there is a lot of of research
out here that says that points out that
it's uh harmful and um you know if you
look at the 390 page report there are
pages and pages of citations of these
types of things we took 14 months and we
looked at a lot of stuff
thank you um if i could ask uh we we're
getting close to our time here uh if
representing kelly pitts if he asks one
question and then i would like to
call on the only person that is right
now is would be speaking against the
bill and give that side an opportunity
before i move on to
this other person who because i've heard
we've heard a lot
on why we should pass the bill and all
that stuff and which is good we need to
hear that but i'd like to hear from the
opposing side before our time runs out
so one question represent kelly pitts
ken
uh i'm picturing a streetscape
polls antennas on poles
so
you go a thousand feet
at you one an antenna what do you do
about the person whose house is less
than a thousand feet from that pole yeah
this is a concern because somebody who
has a second floor front bedroom and has
one on the pole may only be 30 feet away
from that
transmitter and is getting really a high
dosage
from that one and they are also getting
additional from the ones you know
further up and down the street and a
block away and all of those signals
overlap so yeah you get a real
intensification by putting lots and lots
of these down
representatives partial
analogy rather than swimming pools if
you think of lawn sprinklers okay if you
have a lot of lawn sprinklers uh in a in
an area the more of them there are the
wetter you're gonna get and that's
that's exactly what's going on here
i'll follow up with you later
okay thank you very much if you don't
mind uh if i could ask um
uh mr rick fabrizio from bia to come up
uh and give him a few minutes to discuss
before you start talking i just want to
that there are some questions asked
before and i become
uh into some information uh the question
was asked about if any other state had
had banned 5g
best to our knowledge
no states have banned 5g at this point
another
and of course i'll get to this later but
representative kelly pitts is right the
we're preempted by federal law on
certain things that we can do with this
bill and we'll we'll get back to that
later but
apparently our hands could be tied in
some respect but we'll we'll talk about
that later
um
i also want to say that i'm told that
fcc chair rosenworthal is not a lobbyist
that she came that she worked as a
public servant for two
sanders on the senate commerce committee
before joining the fcc to
to democrat sanders another fcc
commissioner jeffrey starks is also not
a lobbyist he was an attorney for
doj focused on law enforcement and
before that focused on national security
before that he was an attorney at a law
clerk at the at the 8th circuit so
those are two examples that that that
they're not
we're not lobbyists at least not at the
time anyway um so with that being said
uh mr fabrizio please go ahead thank you
i am rick fabrizio i'm director of
communications and public policy for the
business and industry association
i would state that if this bill is
passed it would greatly slow new
hampshire's efforts to expand broadband
throughout
states especially the areas that are
unserved
bill as we all know would uh require
setbacks of sixteen hundred forty feet
um from any
you know parks playgrounds residentially
zoned neighborhoods hospitals nursing
homes day care centers and schools you
know if you think about that in reality
you're going to block the deployment of
cell tower telecommunication antenna
virtually everywhere in the state when
you account for the location of all of
those different things it used to be as
part of the telecommunications act of
1996 that highways were identified as
good places where you could put
telecommunication antennae but as we
continue to see increased residential
development in the state more and more
of these new neighborhoods are
encroaching on highways which again is
going to render the placement of
telecommunication antennae if not
possible so greatly restricted that that
is what would stop or
significantly impede the efforts to
expand broadband throughout the state
so there's discussion of you know that
sixteen forty that's six one hundred one
thousand six hundred forty feet
broadband wavelength has a reach of
about a thousand feet again that's going
to render that unusable
the reason why
for 5g is that it provides even though
has lesser range of the previous
generations is that it provides greater
speed and capacity that is the number
one need what we're talking about with
high speed broadband internet speed and
capacity
now we've heard uh today and we've heard
previously in the committee meeting
about the
can't fiber optic do it fiber optic is a
backbone of telecommunication in
industries but it's prohibitively
expensive to route it to the last mile
as you often hear those homes that are
unserved or underserved
so not only is it prohibitedly expensive
it doesn't provide
wi-fi now i'm suppo i suppose there is
some way in your home that you could
connect your phone your mobile phone
to directly to wi-fi but most instances
you're going to need something like a
wi-fi router in order to have your phone
access a fiber optic network
the thing that's most troubling about
this bill is its lack of specifics and
ambiguity the bill clearly sells
telecommunication antennae that would
block just about everything from your
regular cell phone towers to your
distributed antennae systems that offer
a less power lower profile tower than to
the traditional towers
but not only would it block the
distributed antennae systems it would
also block uh public wi-fi which most
providers like comcast at t et cetera
have public wi-fi
antennae if you will located throughout
the street those would also fall under
this even wi-fi and buildings that we
see and we see so many people using
their phones
tablets
chromebooks at all
they would have less ability to connect
to it i would disagree that looking at
5g classifying it as you know 4g is
cellular and 5g is data and nobody needs
to be watching a movie while walking
down the street well i agree they don't
need to be watching a movie while
walking down the street i don't think
that's what the future of 5g is
providing for it's providing for high
speed reliable broadband internet
and it is a crucial part of bringing
wifi to all areas of the state
we've heard a lot today and in the
previous testimony of research that says
it causes harm
it's not a problem this is part of the
process
there are different people's site expert
says it causes harm other experts say
it's not proven to cause harm in the
minority report of the 5g commission
which said that 5g poses significant
health to humans and the environment the
world health organization and the fda
did not support that contention
so
while i'm not going to forgive congress
or any of the other governing bodies for
not moving this up on their list like it
or not this research all has to come
together and be vetted
by an agreed upon agency which should be
a government agency that can take all
the information together and distill a
final report
because one group saying one thing and
one group saying another is not the
answer to this but we do know that the
state needs to continue to expand
broadband for economic purposes from
everything from telehealth to remote
learning to businesses the state is
going to require more and more online
data capacity in order for our economy
to continue to grow and function at the
level it needs to be done
i would ask that you look
strictly at this bill
on the note that it banned it would
preemptively
ban most telecommunication new
telecommunication antennae of all
variety throughout the state
if the goal was to make sure that
they're not placed every 200 meters the
bill should
have looked at that
not set such strict bans that you will
be hard-pressed to find another location
for a cell for a telecommunication
antenna moving forward which again
includes all wi-fi routers i'll be
taking any questions uh thank you uh
before i take any questions i i'd like
to um
read to uh to further substantiate what
represent kelly pittsett said before
about the federal communications act of
1996 and get your
your view on that
um from what i had
this comes from the fcc site
it says that in particular section 704
of the act states that quote
no state or local government or
instrumentality thereof
may regulate the placement construction
and modification of personal wireless
service facilities on the basis of of
the environmental effects of radio
frequency emissions to the extent that
such facilities comply with the
commission's regulations concerning such
emissions
does
uh if if if we were to place
maybe no uh
broad restrictions but if we were to
even set
uh even smaller
distances in the 1640 feet
with this regulation here prevent us
from even doing that
that was what i meant to mention it in
this period but i was kind of going off
the cuff it was one of my initial
concerns with the bill is the fact that
it would run afoul of the
telecommunications act which part of the
reason why it was created was to
facilitate an agreed upon acceptable
placement of telecommunication antennae
i would think that this law as it stands
would be at odds with the federal
regulation
thank you represent kelly pitts
i have i have two questions one was uh
the federal telecommunications act but
we also have
local
zoning in this
state
where zoning boards and local
uh people and at one point i believe
some towers way back in the beginning
were
the subject of the sec
can local boards still regulate the
placement of towers and i'm going to
just follow up with the second question
really quickly is that
you mentioned the cost of price
and that fiber is much more expensive
and we know that a company certain
company left because they didn't want to
do fiber
or expand fiber
what
the criteria for expanding broadband one
of the criteria is affordability
so would 5g roll out
be more affordable
and i mean these are the federal
criteria
with not being an expert on it but
knowing that if you
do the research on fiber optive
fiber optic it's very expensive and then
when you factor in the companies are
putting them in putting it in if you put
in fiber optic in an urban area where
say manchester 110 000 people that cost
per person goes down if you're looking
to run fiber optic to the rural parts of
the state where you might have
five homes per mile
that beca that's when it really becomes
cost prohibitive because the service
providers cannot possibly justify that
type of per household cost because the
numbers the houses are so far they're
separated and there's so many few of
them
um fiber optic is a backbone of it but
again i i would say that
you have to have wireless for the phones
and the tablets and everything else to
connect if you look at the internet of
things in five years more and more
you'll have smart refrigerators
completely controlled heating systems
all this is a wi-fi based thing and yes
that itself can tie into fiber optic but
fiber optic
doesn't right now really bridge the gap
to wireless but again most importantly
it goes back to it's very cost
prohibitive to deliver the last mile of
broadband via fire fiber optic
follow-up
just a quick follow-up is that so the
construction of these small towers
every i don't know how many feet
uh
is going to be far less inexpensive
even though
[Music]
federal money is working the grant for
this delivering fiber optic to the last
mile to those rural areas where you
don't have a density of housing is going
to be cost prohibitive
if you were to rely on the federal
funding you're going to chew through
that federal funding a lot more quickly
if your end goal is to deliver fiber
optic to every house in unserved
underserved rural areas
represent partial
thank you again um
as a recent recipient of high-speed
fiber in my house i've watched my own
bill
uh
decreased by greater than half
my thanks to a bill passed by the house
originating the senate passing the house
we have the ability now to go to our
municipalities
and working bonding with our local and
net companies we are able to go that
last mile at an affordable price
i i'm really wondering if this uh
prohibitive expense is really that
prohibitive when i've seen my own bill
drop
and as far as my telephone works i am
very very happy that i can finally pick
up
because i have a wi-fi router i can
finally hook up my cell phone to get a
voice over internet protocol which i was
not able to get before because i was
lying up on a cell phone service
i find my fiber optic to be of a high
caliber high
high quality product i really
and when we talk about broadband as far
as what we uh have for uh
cellular broadband has to function right
now by definition around 50 megabytes
per second
and while
the claim is that 5g is able to do that
i believe they are if they were able to
densify their towers enough
the cost of getting that 50g i really
would question most most 5g towers are
not putting out nearly that rate so i i
i guess i find myself
conflicted
i would say for sure this isn't an
either or approach to broadband you're
not going to get there all with fiber
optic you're not going to get there all
with wireless this is a composite
of using all the different technologies
to increase broadband access and to
allow for the increased capacity and
increase speed because even what's being
installed now
will have a
shelf life because the amount of data
the amount of online life you know
business shopping banking
entertainment you name it is
increasingly going online the state has
to continue to move forward to make sure
that it has a proper
high-speed internet infrastructure and
as my written testimony had presented
before that it's really not unlike
railroads in the 1800s and highways in
the 1900s or the advent in the
deployment of electricity it's not
unlike that for economic development
it's crucially important and again i
would warn that this bill poses a threat
to that investment because again i don't
see where you're going to cite a new
telecommunication antennae which
includes the full size towers the
distributed antennae systems even public
wi-fi i don't know where you place those
with such strict limits
thank you
i realize
there's probably more questions to be
asked of view but if if i would i would
like to get the next speaker in before
uh noontime
if we as if the subcommittee decides
that we need to come back after lunch we
can
i think we have this room
uh we can decide that after we break for
lunch i said well no we'll decide before
we break for lunch if we need to come
back again but in the meantime let me
ask um
cecilia
johnson
doucet excuse me to come up here thank
you
you're welcome to stay around we may
have further discussion later
good afternoon or good morning still
thank you my name is cecilia ducette i
am the education services director for
an international non-profit called
wireless education i am also the
director of massachusetts for safe
technology and like most of you i had no
idea that there was anything to worry
about with wireless in fact for eight
years i ran campaigns for our public
schools when we were hearing about the
21st century classroom and how our kids
were going to need to have ipads
chromebooks wireless infrastructure so i
was on the wrong side of this and then
one night at book group my girlfriend
wendy who's an electrical engineer
tipped me off that there could be
biological harm
so i am a technical and professional
writer by trade so i just started
looking for the science which is what
the new hampshire commission so
dutifully did
in their
report so really i hope you will all
look at this over the next week very
seriously over the weekend i sent you
all three separate emails the first one
gives the back story on how rep abrami
came into this topic the second one
talks about the report itself and so i
want to tell you who was on that
commission
you know your colleagues here engineers
but we also had
dr gary woods a medical doctor we had dr
tom sherman a medical doctor
we had denise riccardi who is now
senator denise riccardi who fought off
cell towers in her town she's a wealth
of information we also had dr kent
chamberlain we had
former representative wells who has as
you know a scientific background and we
also had dr paul heru
who is one of the world's leading
radiation scientists in fact he has
created cancer in his lab from this
radio frequency and he was coming down
from mcgill university where he teaches
electromagnetics so
this is the first time in our country
that any qualified board has looked at
this issue so please
this is our nation's leading document
today because our federal agencies have
dropped the ball you guys are it
when you look at that minority report
you will find a lot of information in
there that looks really good but what
you're not seeing is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so i
just want to point you to a few bullet
items
they give assurances that you have to
have heat to have harm well as our
experts here have told you we have great
harm happening at the non-thermal level
they also reference the ieee or the
institute for electronics and electrical
engineers which is a wonderful
profession but with all due respect they
are not medical doctors and they are not
emf scientists and as rep abrami stated
he tried to get them to the table but
they had nobody to bring
you should also know that the industry
references dr jeffrey shorin at the fda
dr shurin is married to a partner in a
law firm that represents the wireless
industry he should have been nowhere
near our government studies on radio
frequency radiation
the industry will also indicate the
american cancer society says there's no
harm
but our government completed a 30
million dollar study it's the largest
study the us national toxicology program
has ever completed on any toxin and they
are the gold standard in the world on
toxins
after an unprecedented three-day peer
review at the national institutes of
health with world leading experts
weighing in
in their final report they conclude
clear evidence
of cancerous tumors and dna damage among
other findings clear evidence is the
highest of five categories that they can
assign
so this is not to be taken lightly we do
have conclusive causation now that we
didn't have back in 2011 when the world
health organization classified this as a
group 2b possible human carcinogen
now the industry when a good study comes
out will try to counter that and say oh
that's just one study you need more than
that to prove it well right on the heels
of the u.s national toxicology program
study the ramazzini institute in italy
completed another very large study that
corroborated the findings of cancer and
dna damage that we had here
and the american cancer society said
this is paradigm shifting good science
so what we thought we knew before
doesn't apply anymore
you should also know that the american
cancer society is reporting sharp rises
right now in colon cancers and rectal
cancers among young adults at the very
spots where they're tucking their
devices into their waistbands and into
their back pockets and where they're
holding their tablets
and their ipads their chromebooks so you
need to take everything the industry
says with a grain of salt and then go to
the independent scientific experts for
answers
the world health organization
you need to know that there are two
groups looking at electromagnetic fields
at the world health organization one is
very heavily industry funded the other
is independent scientists
after the u.s and the italian studies
produced the animal studies that were
missing back in 2011 when they declared
it a group to be possible human
carcinogen we now have those the who has
reopened their investigation in 2020 and
in the next couple of years they're
supposed to be weighing in on this but
the question remains will it be
a stacked
agency
project again with industry
and as for the gentleman you recog
referenced with ichnerp the
international commission on non-ionizing
radiation protection that is also a very
heavily industry funded group
so we need to know who we're getting our
information from
the industry will also tell us the
cancer rates are going down but again
when we look at certain cancer rates
like brain tumors francis have
quadrupled where we're holding a cell
phone to our head in england the
incidence of these glioblastoma
multiforma
these are the deadliest types of tumors
they have more than doubled
in india brain tumors in children and
adults are increasing
and the industry tends to focus on
cancer outcomes because that takes the
longest to develop but there are many
many very serious health effects
happening right now
including infertility they've taken male
human sperm
exposed it to a laptop with the antennas
turned on
it changed the dna it slowed the
motility and it caused far fewer sperm
to be viable in just four hours of
exposure
that's actually the set of studies that
got me on my feet and gave me the
courage to speak up because we had just
given my college age daughter a laptop
to go to college with we had just given
my high school age daughter
a laptop to go to high school with and
where are they both using it but right
on top of their reproductive organs and
we now have studies from kaiser
permanente and others that show
increased miscarriage rates with women
who are using radio frequency
communication devices
so when the industry starts discussing
these 5g millimeter waves they once
again turn to the ieee for their
expertise those are not doctors or
scientists
and in fact the ieee
has already put out some studies that
indicate yes there are biological
effects so again every time the industry
tells you something that makes you think
you want to believe what they're saying
dig deeper
in february of 2019 u.s senator richard
blumenthal called out the fcc in a a
federal commerce hearing
and he said to them so please share with
us how much money have you invested
for independent science to prove that 5g
is safe
before we roll this out
and both of those industry
representatives had to fess up that they
don't know of any safety testing that
has been done on this
so we should not be putting this into
our communities
when you talk about before and after i
want to share with you that back in 2019
when rep abrami first introduced
his house bill 522 that led to this law
and this was the first law on the land
to form a commission and to look at this
we were invited to come in in the
morning when the industry
representatives were giving their pitch
on how come new hampshire should get on
the bandwagon and do what boston has
done and get all this new wireless
infrastructure
well i want to tell you what's happened
in boston
so this is a radio frequency radiation
detection meter and it's hard because
these are invisible waves we can't get
our mind around it
but when i turn this on
we will get an ambient reading in this
room and you know it's a little dummy
proof for those of us who don't know the
numbers or the science that well
we know
green yellow red right right here in
this room just the ambient environment
is hitting a peak of 2530
microwatts per square meter and it's
that peak that we need to be very much
aware of because that's what's damaging
our cells so don't listen to any
industry averages it's the spike the
spiked erratic pulse of microwave
radiation that is harming ourselves but
i want to show you what happens when i
take my cell phone out of airplane mode
and i get an active signal
so we were at what 2000 a moment ago
watch how this goes
i'm now at
114 000
microwatts per square meter i went in i
was one of the folks who held on to her
3g phone
and i had to go back to the store
because i got the letter that said
they're going to discontinue 3g
and i got to chatting with a couple of
guys at the store and
i said do you guys want to know why i'm
asking if i can hardwire the replacement
phone and it was slow that day so we
chit-chatted and
one of the kids pulled out his new 5g
phone and when i measured it with the
antennas on for 5g it went over a
million
in our sleeping areas the science
indicates we should be at 0.1
microwatts per square meter
in the outdoor areas they recommend a
thousand or less and that's presuming
that you get to go home
and allow your body the proper space to
detoxify in your own private setting if
you put a cell tower outside of
somebody's home their body is never
going to be able to catch up and then
you see this whole downstream effect and
you know when you go out and you look at
the official websites from our captured
agencies or from ichner
what you will see is information to give
you a false sense of security but the
science has progressed and we know of at
least eight different ways
that this radiation damages our
biological cells
our experts here have talked about
oxidative stress they've talked about
the free radicals we've talked about
infertility
we should also know about the rouleau
effect so
this is a magnetic field our red blood
cells are meant to be free floating and
bringing oxygen to all of our systems
when we are exposed to radio frequency
radiation it can cause our blood cells
to glom up and i remember the the rulo
effect because when i was a kid i like
those candies called rolos that are
stacked up
so instead of free floating
our red blood cells start
flowing up
into this chain that can then no longer
get to where it needs to bring oxygen
to our major organs and every cell in
our body so oxidative stress
and the roulette effect are very very
critically important and we know that in
a controlled
medical setting we can do really good
things with this technology we can
stimulate stem cell growth we can
stimulate bone cell growth but in this
uncontrolled way
that the industry has convinced us that
while all wi-fi all the time is the way
to go
there's no control and there's no escape
from it
so
as much as we've been told that we have
to have wireless our experts here are on
the right path when they tell us that we
should invest as much as we can in
hard-wired
fiber or high-speed cable or copper to
and through
the premises my house completely
hardwired
not hard to do you put an ethernet cable
you put an ethernet jack you buy little
adapters and you hook it all up you
might have to give up a little
convenience maybe you can't walk into
the bathroom with your cell phone
right or put an ethernet jack in your
bathroom and just plug it in
but dr timothy sheckley with the
national institute for science law and
public policy
has a wonderful resource for you called
reinventing wires the future of land
lines and networks wi-fi is great for
the wireless industry
wi-fi is not sustainable when we have
natural disasters look what happened if
the fire is out in california
people could not get a call out because
the cell towers had burnt down those who
still had hardwired land lines could get
emergency response so it's a very very
serious misstep when we allow the
industry to talk us out of maintaining
the landlines
so i hope you will take that very much
to heart and as far as the legalities of
this i would direct you to americans for
responsible technology this is a
non-profit award-winning group
they've received awards from the
environmental protection agency for the
incredible they work work they do to try
and protect our children
they have taken best practices from
around the country that have upheld
in courts of law
the industry will tell you it's coming
there's nothing you can do about it that
telecom act makes it so you can't say
anything about where you want to put
these but that's simply not true
congress preserved our local municipal
rights to a degree
and so i won't go into detail here but
there's a lot that our towns can do
starting with don't put wireless
communication facilities in residential
areas
if you can do it and get you know cover
the gap in coverage
put them in industrial complexes 300
feet up in the air where they're
supposed to be
do not put them in our school yards do
not put them on our hospitals do not put
them on our senior centers and don't put
them on our playing grounds either
so it's all out there and i am telling
you this report has done an incredible
job of making your job easy they spent a
year and a half on this i know you guys
only have a week
but they have done their job and i am
asking that you support
the hard work that went on before this
committee reconvened
and were you able to distribute these to
your full board
i did uh give them out to be distributed
i assume everyone got one yes yeah so
this is an excellent way just to share
with your family share with your loved
ones
what this invisible toxin is
and then just you know start taking your
baby steps at home i can be brought in
to do training sessions i've already
been brought into the keene public
library
i was brought into
taylor community center with the senior
citizens
and i give talks all over the country
all over the world and just step
everybody through this because once we
know
what these risks are
it's just common sense to choose safe
sustainable technology wireless is not
sustainable it's just not hardwire
fiber to and through the premises will
last for years and years and it will
adapt with technology you're not going
to have to keep reinvesting
like they want us to do with all of our
wireless devices so
i thank you for your time i know it's a
lot to get your arms around in a short
amount of time but if there's anything i
can do to help
you know help you connect those dots i
would be so honored
thank you
anyone have a question
okay my uh my question to the
subcommittee is
um
do do you want there's there's at least
one other speaker coming up do you want
to cover that you want a lunch break do
you think we need to come back for some
more discussion
for more than say 15-20 minutes or do
you want to take care of this last
speaker and then we can talk about
whether we need to come back again this
week
represent partial
i'd be happy to defer to your judgment
whatever that may be
however um
i am
i am wondering there was a discuss the
possibility of uh splitting this uh
bill into two
sections one addressing the placement of
cell towers the other the registry
and i'm wondering if we want to address
that as part of this committee as well
and again i'll refer to your judgment on
all of this yeah i um
i i didn't hear that um
i um
not sure we had the time
uh to go into that you know splitting a
bill is is gonna be very difficult i
think at this time
to my recollection said he wouldn't mind
eliminating that registry part of the
bill for right now
yes
right that could certainly be one of our
options that that we can discuss i think
for right now let's i believe
uh mr robert uh michelle roberge is here
and let's continue with her you would
like to hang around may i just make one
more comment
we have developed online training for
schools and families and for the
corporate workplace that can be
completed online off the shelf in about
a half an hour
during this pandemic we had given every
child
a wireless device to access
their education with absolutely no
safety testing
no safety training
and you know that those kids are
sleeping with those tablets
and this is extraordinarily biologically
harmful so regardless of what you do
with this bill
we need to get education out to our
families immediately
and our non-profit would be honored to
give you the licensing to protect the
children in new hampshire and elsewhere
thank you
um
mr roberge come on up come on down
thank you members of the committee
i'll be very brief today
my name is michelle roberge and i'm the
administrator of the bureau of public
health protection within the division of
public health at the department of
health and human services
and i just wanted to remind the
committee
the department is neutral on this bill
but we do have some concerns related to
the registry and i know some of you had
a few questions there is a fiscal impact
to the department
on the registry component of it and i
wanted to just note that there is no
rulemaking authority within the language
of the bill or an appropriation to
support the registry and that's really
our our
our only concern is if we're asked to do
this registry that there is no
appropriation and there's no rule making
and we filed a fiscal note and we also
provided testimony during the public
hearing as well thank you uh would we
remind everybody that there is going to
be a public hearing continuation on this
bill i believe on february 7th in the
morning
to take care of the speakers i think
that didn't get a chance to speak if if
i'm correct on that and then there'll be
an exact session in in the afternoon so
yeah
the hearing's at one i'm sorry
yeah yes you're right one o'clock
well i
um i'll have to double check on that i
know there's going to be a public
hearing done
right i know i can't be here in the
morning but i'll be here in the
afternoon
so
okay uh any other questions
okay uh so my question to the
subcommittee now is
do you see a need to come back this
afternoon for more discussion amongst us
or
we could
i'll i'll check and see if we're able to
have another subcommittee meeting maybe
this thursday if it's if it's allowable
i don't know if who's available
you have to be able on thursday
what's your favorite what's the
subcommittee feeling on this
turn on
how is the subcommittee going to make a
recommendation if we don't discuss it
that that's all i want to say
availability
we're here
um
can we have
you know 15 20 minutes and not have to
have a lunch at 12 30. sure
that's why i'm asking you know we can
yeah
that would be fine with me i know
there's another hearing going on at one
o'clock in the state house
but how can we make a recommendation
exactly thoughts
i have thoughts
i'm just
the results of any given study depends
largely upon who pays for the study and
i always keep that in mind
and there's so much conflicting
information out there it's like who do
we believe you've got one set of
scientists that says this you got this
one set of scientists it says that
who's to say that this side is correct
and this side is wrong
because again who pays for the study and
all right
let's take climate the climate we have
one set of scientists that says we're in
a climate crisis we're all going to die
and then i learned that there's tens of
thousands of scientists worldwide that
that say we're not in a climate crisis
and
they don't get any credence because they
don't go along with what an
administration
decided
is true
therefore they're canceled so
we had the commission and
they spent a year and a half but
i don't want to use the word stacked
because it sounds doesn't sound nice but
but it was because the other side wasn't
part of it for whatever reason
and i i just i'm having a really hard
time with this because
we have to think about new hampshire as
a whole and we can't just
stop industry on
when there's still information out there
from studies that say that
it's inconclusive
i'm just
and if when in doubt throw it out i
don't
those are my thoughts
represent white do you have any comments
i haven't heard from you for a while uh
so my main concerns around this were the
the financial aspect if we can if we can
go closer oh sorry my main
concerns were around the uh
the 1.5 million over three years that's
ridiculous
so if we get rid of that and only focus
on the
the tower location piece of it um
i'm not certain uh honestly i i want to
dive into the report that and all the
studies that are that the report
references so i need like i don't know
60 hours no sleep
uh we don't have 60 hours unfortunately
represent cali pits i
i would
like to see this subcommittee recommend
to the full committee that this go into
interim study
i think we do not know
i mean there's so much conflict we we
know that
something is going on are we going to
stop industry no
industry will march on an industry
there's going to be a federal roll out
all these things are coming
there's also an rsa where we gave up
uh control of the tele telecommunication
industry that we did in new hampshire as
well as the
the act
but i would like to delve
more into exactly what's happening
and come to a fair conclusion we heard
majority one side of this whole story
i would like to read that report
and then i would like to
go with the other side of the story i
know canada has just done a roll out
well what does roll out mean there's all
these questions
and i don't have answers to them i did
go by where i used to work in portsmouth
and look at this
humongous tower that seems to have grown
up next to the senior citizens
department as oh wait a minute
um
so i think i think at this point the
recommendation if that's possible
i would like to see interim study and
forget the amendment for now we because
if we go into interim we can we can take
that out at any time
the registry part
and just look into what the consequences
of
this new rollout is going to be okay
uh
what represent parts do you have
one way or the other
um
yes i think that right where i'm sitting
right now that i feel like i could have
my mind changed i've seen this bill as
something that ought to pass
as long as
as a rep said with white said we could
remove that one part about the self
reporting registry i think we're opening
a can of worms with that
but i think there's enough
enough information right now that we can
go ahead and
recommend this bill to ought to pass and
we can always go back and revisit it
later on if we are concerned about
stifling industry in the state of new
hampshire i think it's a more
conservative approach
and i think we've heard a good amount of
textimony today about the dangers of emf
radiation
and also about how
many of the people are speaking of it
are only are speaking from uh the
lobbyists they have something to make
from this we're seeing private citizens
come forward and say
they don't have a vested interest in the
project itself but they have concerns
i i think that's so i would say that i
would recommend this without one
abutment as an otp
well if we did the amendment it would be
an otpa but but um
i'm i'm i'm not so sure that we we want
to go that route per se
i i do like the thought of the interim
study
because
whichever way we go we would need more
time to formulate
a proper response
i wouldn't be opposed to the interim
study on that representative i agree
with um what rep representative kelly
pitts said and you normally i don't
i'm against studies to become what are
you going to study you got to study the
study but there there is another side to
the whole issue and there's there is
more to study it would give us at least
time to formulate some type of perhaps
an amendment uh instead of just trying
to secure it this week representative
white
so if we refer this to interim study
what does that mean what's the timeline
look like i i'm not really sure how that
works
normally
interim study during the second year of
a biennium
normally they're used to sometimes just
make a bill go away but i would not want
that to happen in this case we would
have the authorization to schedule
another
um
study
uh on this i i'm not sure if the
subcommittee would be it's probably a
subcommittee involved with the interim
study on that but we could it's possible
we could also schedule a full committee
work session too
so we have those options available to us
it'll be up to a chairman votes to
decide on um on on how he wants to go
with that but here as a subcommittee we
could recommend
to the full committee that we that we do
interim study and the full committee
would vote on that and should it pass
then uh we would i don't even think we
have i don't even that doesn't even come
up for a vote before the full house it
just goes into interim study in which
case
both vo's and i would be responsible for
us to schedule the next meetings for you
know for the study
okay pitts do we
do we have to vote
on
the bill is this this is an early bill
is that correct
no this is not an early bill it's not an
early bill is it
i didn't think it was it it has an fn
but i didn't think it was an early bill
quickly yeah it's an early bill because
of the second part of the bill because
it mentioned in the fiscal note ftes and
stuff like that
i did talk to the speaker about it i
said can the committee just if they
amend it out it's still going to have to
go to the floor
and
so
no i i i i i it's it's it has to be
voted out next week but we can recommend
interim study
yes and and absolutely and the committee
would vote on that and i i i don't
believe interim study comes up before
the it does it on the floor but that's
okay i was told listen if this is the
will of the group
i i would support interim study as long
as it's not at
the uh polite death okay yeah no no we i
i i definitely want to have another
study at least if for no other reason
for the purpose of formulating either an
amendment a proper amendment
my personal feeling is i i just don't
think
i just don't think there's enough
evidence to to stay with the the
distance factor as stated there might be
a compromise here somewhere i don't know
and the registry
i think we're going to have i would
support it if
the goal of the of the of these
let's not call it this continuation of
this discussion
is basically what we're talking about
i think you find members who are i'm
sure we're gonna you can find at least
seven members or more that would be
interested in continuing this
conversation
what i'm gonna suggest is that
what cc doucet just handed i'll hand it
out to you to have a copy of each one of
you this may be a good starting point as
to how do we
what can we do because yes we all are
all against up against the 1996
telecommunication act we know that
it was became a question to me whether
new hampshire was bold enough to take on
the federal government
uh and we had i was i was going to see
what would happen here if i was going to
go to the governor and say
would you even sign this
and because realizing that we would have
to take on the federal government
because that'll cost the state money to
to battle that out
but i think here with this what's what's
here is a good starting point for the
discussion of
how do we craft this so that we can keep
our citizens safer empower
ability to empower our municipalities
more
within the structure of
of
maybe a better approach
and uh you know you know i i can see i
can see the writing on the wall that's
why i'm saying what i'm saying here
uh yes there's a lot of open questions
it takes a while to absorb all this
information
and uh
again i've concluded in my mind there is
this is this
some of the concerns are very real
but i think there's some things we can
do as a state
that would not put us at loggerheads
with the um with the federal government
i mean we could go with loggerheads
there were some openings because of the
court cases that i mentioned
and there are future court cases coming
up that are going to hopefully expose
this whole thing for what it is
but uh for the time being if it's an
interim study and if we really and i i
i'd love to join you
in that effort
and i can bring any experts you want the
other side can bring experts that you
want
and represent an honor
we gave ctia every opportunity to bring
in as many witnesses as they wanted to
they brought in one fellow from the
university of swanson
from university of pittsburgh
who was clearly
paid big money to be there
and did not give us
any studies to the reverse of it you
know it was it was unbelievable all the
other people we gave him a chance and i
said to i said to her
i i said to uh
i'm losing her name now uh
bet uh cooley
i said
give us give us your best shot bring in
more people i want to hear from them
you know and they didn't produce anybody
else
and i you know it isn't like we didn't
try we did try
uh to to bring in more of the other side
and that's why we had
we purposely in the bill we we say that
we wanted industry people there
just so we can have that real true
dialogue on this and i hope when we
continue the discussion in the interim
study that the industry does does
produce some people
but
um you know
anyway i'll leave with that but i'm
gonna hand these out before you leave
just so uh just so some people here uh
understand my understanding
if we if we uh as a subcommittee here uh
vote to recommend interim study and our
committee votes to have interim study
that will
result in a study
but the the results from the interim
study will only produce a
recommendation of what could be
submitted as a bill in the next biennium
so it'll have so you'll have to wait
another cycle for any thing to happen
so
that's how how that works
yes yes and and i think this is a
situation where i think it's well worth
having additional study like i said for
no other reason but to formulate a
proper wording for either uh
an
amendment or a new bill or whatever we
want to recommend on that i think we
don't have enough time right now to
write something for next week
another parliamentary question
if this was amended
and went to the floor
could we recommend tabling and then if
we wanted to use the rest of this
season
bring it back off the table
the table just another
right tabling is an option i
think if it's done
i forget the timeline but there's a
certain timeline where you'd have to
have a two-thirds majority to take it
off the table um i don't think we're
there yet but it's it's possible
you answer that question that question
only
the uh what happens after crossover then
it's going to take a two-thirds vote to
get it off the table
which will be hard to do
right
uh i would also recommend that if we if
we go into that we we try to
get the ear of
some senators to find out what their
thoughts might be on that because
it would uh it would help yes
representative platt yes good to see you
i'm not on the committee so i kept my
mouth shut through most of this and you
don't play one on tv either do you yeah
what po say you don't play one on tv
either do you what
people like a rep
anyway it crossed my mind when the
discussion of table came up is that this
is an early bill and so you have to do
something with it okay
okay
my apologies i i knew there were some
bills out there that were fns that we
had that were not early bills i didn't i
forgotten this one was so
it's an important bill though
represent partial
i could be very much in favor of interim
study if that's what the majority of us
feel however my concern with interim
study is that the fcc has already
asserted its authority in this area
and without something like this
intervening
could we expect them to continue to
assert their authority
well with no action being done right now
there the industry will forge your head
i'm sure okay that's that's my only
concern with interim studies opposed
with otps
we don't have timelines from the
industry what is rollout meat there is
some 5g around
you know we we really don't know that
and is it within the next six months
i probably think so within the next six
six months to a year but we don't have
any information like that that that's
really crucial that's true and even if
we did
recommend otpa and even if we
voted recognition recommendation otpa
and even if it did pass the house
it would still have to wait and go to
the senate and go through their
deliberation and it's
possible they could
not approve it or if they did you still
have until at least what june at least
before it got to the governor's desk and
then there's a possibility of whether it
would be signed or not so the time limit
is far down the future anyway so while
that's going on
there's nothing to prevent the industry
from forging ahead with with what
they're doing
but there's also nothing to prevent the
industry which really just
it makes me distraught from coming and
talking to us and sitting down
and
truly discussing this not just in a pub
but discussing this with us like we
called stakeholders together before and
and
understood what was going on and what
their timelines were and what our
timelines were and are there any
compromise
you know maybe the 1600 feet is too much
maybe
is there any way we can compromise on
this and what are their plans right well
that was one reason why i was sort of
suggesting if we wanted to meet again
this week and invite them here for
another subcommittee meeting but that if
that's not really uh possible for our
subcommittee uh the interim study we
would certainly invite them to come and
implore them to come
i think we have some representatives
here that hopefully will get that
message back to them anyway
yes representative daughter a couple of
things i'm
curious to know if
there are other states that are
talking about
blocking 5g
and if not why does new hampshire have
to be the first one
and
also can i make an official motion to
[Music]
recommend interim study
are we done discussing
let's have an answer the question first
and then
i will ask for a motion
thank you yes massachusetts has 20 bills
to address technology safety
um your commission bill
is being replicated new york has two
bills that does a lot of what you guys
already did here so you guys are
the leaders in the country but many
other states are doing this i was
brought in on a panel in michigan
and if you go to my personal research
repository which is in my signature on
the communication i've been sending to
you
go to understanding emfs
i have a page in there for bills in
other states and you can see what other
states are doing and thank you for being
the first to take meaningful action
you're leading the way if i may ask
could you send
uh you could you send the entire
committee
all uh
either links or documents as to what you
just said
so we could see what's what's happening
in the rest of the country
absolutely okay thank you and the sooner
the better thank you
well right now
i'll be asking for motion in a second do
we have questions uh represent personal
again i don't want a prolonged
conversation here but what would happen
if we just adjourned for the day we will
be hearing testimony in another week
could we carve out
two minutes of time to take an in-person
vote on this but in the interim use that
time to look at more closely this
material and maybe have a
lively
conversation through some other process
internet or something would i know if
that's i don't know if that's possible
i'm asking actually that that is a very
good suggestion it we we could do that i
mean it wouldn't take more than
45 seconds to for us to go through a
motion after we hear the rest of the
public
testimony it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea to hear
the rest of the public testimony how
does the rest of the subcommittee feel
about that
i would approach the chair and say we
need to carve out five minutes prior to
opening up executive session for the
subcommittee to
to
vote for a recommendation that we could
bring forth during the uh executive
session
i
i know this can it cuts into everybody's
lunch time but why not even a half hour
meet at 12 30 we're going to have a
public hearing at
one which i don't know how well attended
it would be but maybe some of the people
from the industry might show up and say
something
meaningful
uh i'm sorry we're suggesting that we
have
that we have at least a half an hour
before the opening of the public hearing
who's we the subcommittee the
subcommittee and so is it your intent to
take a vote before the public hearing or
after the public hearing
i would say that we should take a vote
after the public hearing but five
minutes because then you're going into
an executive session at two okay so so
your recommendation would be for us to
come back as a subcommittee uh at 12 30
on the 7th to have a little more
discussion
open up the public hearing here
additional public hearing and then
before executive session starts we can
uh have a vote on what we want to
recommend but the public hearing does
have to start at two just so that you
know i mean the executive session uh
public hearing has to start at one just
just ahead an executive session can
start anytime afterwards really after
two edges
can't start before two but anytime after
that i think
what do you think
well if it's up to me then uh let's do
that let's schedule the next public next
subcommittee meeting at 12 30 on the 7th
i think we have to
announce it
does that give us time on the seventh
though
that would come out on the that would
come out next thursday right yeah and
that would give us time
all right
are we all in favor of that we don't
take a vote but
okay
next subcommittee meeting i will
schedule for 12 30 on the 7th
and a vote to follow after public
hearing on 1644 ends
thank you thank you thank you for coming
thank you here thank you for coming a
lot of good information to be passed on
science is never ending science has
never settled we always have to go
through testing so thank you for your
thank you for your information thank you
subcommittee is closed
20 37 pages of the report i'm going to
send you the whole report
you know
jennifer
i didn't speak
right
so i'll save the comments